un film che poi lei che ti difendi
perito della gt ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj oggi siamo su un
blog
nella nuova casa grazie a dio devo fare
sto blog tipo anni fa però sono riuscito
a farlo solo adesso non son riuscito a
fanno un cazzo di video rover presentava
la mia casa decentemente adesso ci siamo
ma ci arriviamo più avanti ragazzi
perché prima di cominciare come al
solito di partire con la fan ardea
settimana che pensa settimana è stata
vinta da lobby che ha fatto sto disegno
bellissimo sud e in therapy dove io sono
un figo ma nella realtà di tutti i
giorni sembra quasi una patata con la
barba a sino a sabato
partiamo col fatto che ringrazio tutti
coloro che mi hanno scritto dei miei
commenti sul film perché ci siamo
veramente impegnati tantissimo e questa
settimana quindi questo sabato a questa
domenica saranno gli ultimi giorni in
cui verrà trasmesso nei cinema poi lo
toglieranno ovviamente uniti film nel
caso voleste andare a vederlo avete solo
più fino a sabato domenica ve lo dico
perché se poi mi chiedete fa viva perché
non c'è più avete solo più questo sabato
questa domenica io vi ringrazio di cuore
per tutti i commenti che mi avete
lasciato per il fatto che alcuni hanno
pianto sul finale cioè dio mia c'è una
cosa che mi sono sempre chiesto chissà
come cazzo reagiscono gli attori quando
sanno che qualcuno tipo di caprio di
capre mondo fatto di tani tutti quelli
che ha visto titanic me compreso hanno
pianto come delle teche e mi sono sempre
chiesto a cui si sente di caprio quando
la gente piange vedendo un suo film
adesso che lo so perché alcuni mi hanno
scritto che hanno pianto è strano è
stranissimo mimico muovere sta cosa
veramente bello ovviamente è meglio mi
sto paragonando d cabrio e ci mancherà
di io sono molto molto meglio cioè di
che cazzo stamparla grazie di tutto
ragazzi è stato veramente un sogno io
credo che domani andrò a vederlo di
nuovo per la quarta volta perché non so
se mi capiterà mai più di rivedermi sul
grande schermo quindi sarà un'emozione
pazzesca cercherò di godermi non al
massimo quest'ultima volta se ci sarà se
sarà l'ultima poi non so bene
[ __ ] stando le cose divertenti e
ragazzi preparatevi per promuovere il
film se andate a xfactor perché xfactor
cia chiamati mentre ero lì a xfactor mi
sono fatto mettere delle sopracciglia
tipo quelle di elio e sono riuscito a
trovare mara maionchi ed elio
la ragazza il video della maionchi
questa è una perla ragazzi ve lo dico a
fare un film che poi dimettiti di
credito di cui lei stessa cosa per elio
anche lui è rimasto emozionato e di nate
o dare loro bravate me l'hanno incollate
non so con cosa in sé immolate bene
comunque genere quelli che limitano si
mettono delle merde e dove sorini
passato il pezzo forte del video perché
allora mi avete tutti chiesto fari per
cui non fai un video nella tua nuova
casa e allora passiamo al fa vi risponde
visto che mi avete tempestato di domande
la prima domanda arriva da mel ebay che
mi chiede favi puoi farci vedere la tua
nuova favi casa e facciamolo sta minkia
divide ragazzi datemi l'energia per
battere majin bu vi prego non sono scema
è la prima cosa che ho pensato quando ho
visto quel cazzo di lampadario questa è
la sala gran cosa ci possa di game
therapy mentre questa è l'entrata questo
è il bagno cesso sono una persona molto
ordinata tengo le cose a caso sì ma sì
chi cazzo se ne frega tanto non c'è mia
madre e deve una roba un po strana
perché questo possa dire intera più che
ho messo all'entrata in altri ragazzi
non c'è ancora un cazzo in casa mia
perché è nuova tra virgolette quindi non
ho messo niente i torcetti aperti a caso
gli oro ciò che messi così questo è
sporco ma non ci voglia di pulirlo e
[ __ ] mentre penso forte nella casa
ragazzi secondo me la mia mensola che
fighissima perché ci stanno tipo dice di
tutto c'è la merda nel caso vi steste
chiedendo che cosa mica ci fa una
lampada su monitor non sono un pazzoide
c'è un motivo in realtà quando faccio il
video accendo la lampada perche
l'illuminazione aiuta nel senso civico
così con la lampada accesa e così
siccome la casa e nuova non potevo
mettere perché io di solito la lampada
ciò attaccata al muro non non potevo
farlo allora mi sono dovuto arrangiare
così ho messo una lampada di lato tutta
storta
l'ho messa sul monitor a progetto è così
e così che io mi siedo e mi sparatutto
in faccia e sembra che
che sia il giorno ma non è giorno c'è
semplicemente una lampada nell'occhio
big money 2 milioni di iscritti
all'illuminazione una lampada de merda
sul monitor storta
subito dopo c'è chi dice che va
quell'albero è pieno zeppo di uccelli
devo trovare qualcosa da mangiare fermi
da darmi qualcosa da lanciare questo
questo questo che cazzo ma insomma ma
[ __ ] chi siete che giudichiamo
motion drago tanti barca ma serio poi
comunque ragazzi metterò anche le pagine
this land airmen che ovviamente mancano
semplicemente sono pigro e non ci ha
avuto ancora voglia di mettere ma poi le
metterà un sacco di roba che questa
stanza quando la vedrete più così tra
l'altro ragazzo ci sono ancora dei pezzi
di sopracciglia finte tipo questo che
non si sono ancora staccati e non riesco
a staccarli perché mi fa un male boia ce
l'hanno usato il cemento come colla
[ __ ] mario marian favino fare i
giochi horror cento per cento no fai
solo 70 per cento e 60 per cento
che cosa cazzo avrà voluto dire federico
ramo li fai risponde però cercare favi
su youporn giusto per vedere se escono
cose strane anomalie che sono a casa mia
e mia madre non vede la cronologia c'è
un cazzo da ridere una volta è successo
ma scherzi o forse no vabbè quello che
non mi si apre la pagina spiegato
intriga è così aperto oh mio dio sia un
ragno come cazzo è che in import aa
perché è halloween
ok torino erotica oddio ma che cazzo
madison fa o mio dio
ok anche da che cazzo di parte si guarda
stata ma che si ok non c'è non ci sono
grazie a dio che stanotte io e la
lampada faremo
notte finirà su youporn ero lampada e
non era svenuta pari perché non metti su
famiglia o vent'anni e ne dimostro 15 e
mette al suo famiglia per me
significherebbe farlo su the sims fiume
vpro fare un video mentre fai un corso
di break dance e io io non voglio fare
un corso di breakdance e non rientra nel
mio stile di vita però prima ti droghi
rompi la tastiera così riferisce al
video quello di giovedì dove
praticamente scassato la tastiera perché
sono volati i tasti comunque ragazzi io
concludo che l'episodio spero che nido
vi sia piaciuto in realtà ragazzi la mia
tasca ero incazzato seriamente rincasato
perché era mezzanotte e non avevo ancora
mangiato e quando io non mangio divento
cattivo c'è nel senso io sclero miglior
gioco da fare mentre ero così sclerato
era ovviamente un regime in bo iniziato
a sclerare talmente tra in quel video mi
sono incazzato sul serio ragazzi ma
veramente tanto fate finta di non averlo
visto rom che mi sono saltati i tasti
però gli ori messi perché sta tastiera
in realtà si stacca mit astice proprio
ci si stacca la roba alcuni tasti gli ho
persi perché tipo il tasto due è
diventato questo qua non c'è più il
duello perso f5 uguale fd fa vj fa vj
cinque lettere
c a farvi una brutta notizia john cena è
morto in john cena e quindi ragazzi
concludo che l'episodio e prima di
concludere devo farvi la fai domanda che
questa settimana mi sembra più che ovvia
cioè che ci sono come vorreste che
addobbi addobbi nobili harry potter come
posso riempire di gli oggetti figli la
stanza che vedete alle mie spalle
pensavo di mettere le pagine this lander
me ma se vi vengono delle idee fatemelo
sapere modo che piaccia anche a voi
visto che in qualche modo ci vivrete
anche voi in questa stanza magari anche
nel mio letto come rimorchiare su
youtube parte un'ora che in realtà
volete tutti dormire in una stanza dove
c'è una lampada storta i ragazzi fatemi
sapere spero che mi do vi sia piaciuto e
como se il seguito è piaciuto questo è
un mi piace anche a base di facebook con
ivy dal fratello iscrizione servizi
discreti i cibi chiaro ha proseguito è
lasciato mi piace assolutamente per mara
maionchi manà sport madre teresa ha
fatto un appello ragazzi